derek carr is the guy who on june 22
2017 became the highest paid player in
football history with a contract having
a new money value of 25 million per year
in fewer than 22 months since then that
bar has gone from 25 to 27 to 27.5 to 28
to 30 to 33.5 now it's at 35 million a
year in fewer than 22 months and with
more quarterbacks on the way for new
deals dak prescott
the the guy who is on deck right now
stephen jones the cowboys co said on
tuesday that that hey aaron rodgers and
russell wilson they've won super bowls
which i think is a backhanded slap at
prescott for not winning a super bowl
and expecting to be in that stratosphere
but i don't know why jones is even
talking about that stratosphere chris i
don't care that russell wilson's at 35
million dak prescott was never going to
be in that range anyway and it makes me
wonder are dak prescott's agents
suggesting that this is just hey this is
the way it works one guy gets the most
ever and then the next guy gets the most
ever and the next guy gets the most ever
i think that this has reached its limit
as it relates to dak prescott he's in
the 25 to 30 range he's not in the 30 to
35 or more range and and i i kind of
wonder are are his agents making that
case why else would stephen jones feel
compelled to differentiate rogers and
wilson well yeah i mean i think it's a
good point i mean yes i would think
maybe the agent of course is asking for
you know sky's the limit to start this
uh contract negotiation talks but i mean
maybe stephen jones is being asked
specifically about the russell wilson
contract situation and comes with comes
being asked about russell wilson as you
talk about the guy he just one-upped a
little bit there with aaron rodgers and
they're the two highest paid in the game
but i do think you know just the common
fan i think does look at it that way
right now next guy up gets the most
money right that's the way it goes
but to your thought and i think you're
spot on i mean i think realistic you
know
dak prescott category of money is
somewhere between that 25 and 30 million
dollar contract somewhere in that range
yes there's no way that jimmy garoppolo
deserves to be make more money than dak
prescott listen i understand and we
could say jimmy garoppolo is better or
all those things or has better potential
whatever it may be the fact of the
matter is he hasn't proved it yet and
dak prescott has been to the playoffs
twice and delivered in some big moments
and been on the field for every game of
a three-year career so uh he has every
right to ask for that price range or
kirk cousins same thing that's where the
market went haywire to me it's not when
aaron rodgers got paid or russell wilson
got paid it's you talking about derek
carr becoming the highest paid
quarterback ever because he was in the
mvp conversation in a year where he
ended up breaking his legs and then even
a leg i should say and then didn't get
to play in a playoff game but became the
richest quarterback ever off of that and
then you had the guys to follow it up
like kirk cousins and jimmy garoppolo
who got paid like they were big time
franchise quarterbacks and i just don't
think they were worthy of that dollar
but team these teams needed a
quarterback and they overpaid a little
bit for them
yeah it went one after another car
stafford garoppolo cousins and among
them combined not a single playoff win
prescott can at least now say he has
that i think he lands in that 25 to 30
range my concern from the cowboys
perspective by focusing on guys above
that range you may inadvertently result
in dak prescott being closer to the top
of that 25 to 30 million dollar per year
range but we'll see how that works out
and the ultimate leverage for prescott
is to say we'll just do the franchise
tag dance 2020 2021 and then in 2022
you're going to be facing a hell of a
decision because it's a 44 raise over
what will be about a 30 million dollar
cap number for him if they go franchise
tagging if he makes it to the second
year of the tag like demarcus lawrence
did before signing his new contract
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports